[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحاديه عشره
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
ازدحام سماء غزه بالصواريخ عوده التصعيد
وميت ان المعركه لم تنتهي حتى الان
الرياض تستانف عمل بعثتها الدبلوماسيه في
دمشق وتوجه دعوه للاسد لحضور القمه
العربيه
من الخرطوم الى بورتسودان نازحون يلاحقون
مراكز غسيل الكلى بعد تعطلها في العاصمه
بسبب القتال
اوكرانيا تعلن شن هجمات مضاده في باخموت
دفعت القوات الروسيه وفاغنر للتراجع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه رشقات صواريخ
واعمده دخان وصافرات انذار هكذا بدل مشهد
في غزه بعدما اعلنت اسرائيل اطلاق ما
وصفته بوقت الاغتيالات فلليوم الثاني على
التوالي قصف الطائرات الاسرائيليه اهدافا
في قطاع غزه منها بيت لاهيا شمالي القطاع
وموقعا تابعا لكتائب القسام في عسقلان
وادى القصف الاخير بحياه رجل واحد واصاب
اخر بجروح خطيره جاءت الغارات الاخيره بعد
يوم من سلسله هجمات داميه اغتالت ثلاثه من
قياده الجهاد الاسلامي الجيش الاسرائيلي
عاد مره اخرى ليؤكد ان الهدف من القصف هو
استهداف البنيه التحتيه لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي كما اوضح ان الغاره الجويه
استهدفت مسلحين متجهين الى موقع اطلاق
صواريخ في قطاع غزه الجنوبي
[موسيقى]
ل بشلوشه مقديم للس
حركته الجهاد الاسلاميه لم تتاخر في الرد
حيث اطلقت وابلا من الصواريخ ونقلا عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي فان حركه الجهاد هي
المسؤوله عن اطلاق هذه الصواريخ التي
اشارت الى ان حركه حماس لم تدخل المعركه
حتى الان وفق الجيش الاسرائيلي وفي اخر
احصائيه فانه تم اطلاق 469 صاروخا من قطاع
غزه وجرع اعتراض 153 صاروخا افادت مراسله
العربيه بان عدد الصواريخ التي تم اطلاقها
من قطاع غزه وصل عدد منها الى تل ابيب حيث
تم تفعيل صافرات الانذار وتم اعتراض هذه
الصواريخ بواسطه القبه الحديديه واظهرت
مقاطع مصوره هروب السكان الى الملاجئ كما
ادى الهجوم الى تعطل حركه الملاحه الجويه
في مطار بن غوريون
اظهرت صور اطلاق صواريخ على مناطق وسط
اسرائيل وايضا ذوي وسفارات الانذار في
عسقلان في الجنوب نتابع المشاهد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال رئيس وزراء اسرائيل بنيامينه وان
اسرائيل اصابت اهدافا بدقه في غزه مشيرا
الى ان المعادله الامنيه الجديده هي ان
اسرائيل ستحدد الوقت المناسب لاستهداف
قاده الفصائل الفلسطينيه
نحن في خضم المعركه قوتنا تقوم بتوجيه
ضربات قويه وندمر كل من يمس بنا او يعمل
ضدنا هذا هو المبدا الذي نتعامل به في
اطار عمليه الدرع والسهم اوجدنا معادله
جديده نقول للمخربين ومرسليهم نراكم في كل
مكان ولا تستطيعون الاختباء ونحن نختار
المكان والزمان الذي نضربكم خلاله نحن
ولستم انتم بهدوء وليس كرد فعل الخيار لنا
انزلنا على الجهاد في غزه اقوى ضربه في
تاريخها
الاسرائيلي في تصريح له ان المعركه في غزل
لم تنتهي بعد معلنا لان ضربات الاسرائيليه
دمرت انفاقا للفصائل الفلسطينيه ومصانع
للصواريخ
[موسيقى]
دمرنا انفاقا يستخدمها مطلق الصواريخ في
غزه ووجهنا ضربات لمصانع الصواريخ وكانت
ناجحه ودقيقه المعركه لم تنتهي لم تتوقف
نامل ان نصل الى نهايتها قريبا ولكن نبقى
على استعداد وسنستمر كلما لزم الامر
نتابع مباشره من قطاع غزه معنا من هناك
الصحفيه روان الصراني روان اهلنا بك معنا
يبدو ان هناك المزيد من الصواريخ يتم
اطلاقها من القطاع باتجاه المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه
مساء الخير اسمح لي ان ابدا
بالسياسه الجديده لربما في الساعه الاخيره
التي انتهجتها اسرائيل
بقصف منازل فلسطينيه حيث تهدف قبل ساعه من
الان منزل مكون من ثلاث طوابق في منطقه
القراره شرق خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه ومنزل
اخر يتبع لعائله المصري في بيت لاهيا
وربما هذا نهج جديد اتبع قبل ساعه من الان
بعد تركيز اسرائيل لقصفها على
اراض او منصات لاطلاق الصواريخ ومقدرات
تتبع للفصائل العسكريه الفلسطينيه وتحديدا
الجهاد الاسلامي بالتاكيد كان هناك رد من
قبل الجهاد الاسلامي ويمكننا القول بانه
تحذير
كلامي جاء على لسان قاده في الجهاد
الاسلامي بان اتجاه اسرائيل نحو سياسه قصف
المنازل
للفلسطيني معلومات
اكثر عن هذه المنازل وقاطنيها كذلك التي
استهدفتها اسرائيل في الساعه الاخيره كما
تفضلتي
لا اصابات يعني في القصف الاخير الذي طال
منزلين واحد في شرق خان يونس جنوب قطاع
غزه والاخر في شمال قطاع غزه
لاصابات ولكن المنازل سويت بالارض بالكامل
خاصه وانها استهدفت من قبل الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي الجهاد الاسلامي حذرت وبشكل
واضح بان تحول اسرائيل نحو هذه السياسه
باستهدافها للمنازل سيقابل بتكثيف لقصف
بالصواريخ سيصل لتل ابيب وللعمق
الاسرائيلي ولكن الساعه الاخيره بعد هذا
القصف لم يذكر انه تم استهداف اي من منازل
الفلسطينيين اسرائيل وفي اخر ما رشح عن
مصادرها تقول باننا بانها قصفت او استهدفت
133 هدفا في غزه يتبعون
لمواقع
ومخازن انتاج اسلحه ومقدرات تحت ارضيه
تتبع للفصائل العسكريه الفلسطينيه وبالاخص
للجهاد الاسلامي
عن الوساطه عذرا على المقاطعه مصادر قالت
ان الجهاد تلقت سبعه اتصالات من الوسيط
المصري بشان شروط وقف اطلاق النار روان
تسمعينني وانا اتح الواضح ان هناك قصف من
قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه لا ندري
اين هو حتى اللحظه
من غزه معك روان اذا تنقلين لنا على
الهواء مباشره سماعدوي انفجارات لعلها
ربما تكون اصوات جديده اذا اسرائيليه
مستمره اذا في قطاع غزه ربما نتحرى المزيد
من التفاصيل بعد قليل ربما بعد قليل ترشح
المزيد من التفاصيل ولكن روان في انتظار
ذلك ما المعلومات التي لديك حول جهود
الوسيط المصري وشروط الجهاد الاسلامي لوقف
اطلاق النار
ساده تفاؤل في الشارع الفلسطيني من قبل
المواطنين لربما وفي كافه الاوساط وسائل
الاعلام اكدت بان الاختبار سيكون في
الساعه التاسعه
بدخول التهدئه حيز التنفيذ ولكن
واضح ان هناك اعاقات وعرقله ترجعها
اسرائيل الى
تصميم الجهاد الاسلامي او اشتراطاته
تتوقف اسرائيل عن سياسه الاغتيالات وان
تقوم بتسليم جثمان الاسير خضر عدنان هذا
ما رفضته اسرائيل حيث ان اسرائيل تريد
وقفا والواضح انها تريد وقفا لاطلاق النار
بلا شروط والواضح ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وتحديدا الجهاد الاسلامي مصره على قضيه
وقف الاغتيالات مقابل
ادخال التهدئه حيز التنفيذ بحيث الانباء
الاخيره تقول بانه لا وقف
للتهدئه خاصه في ظل التعليقات التي [__] نا
اليها من قبل نتنياهو رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي الذي قال اننا لا زلنا في خضام
التصعيد او في خضم هذه
المعركه ما رد عليه قيادي من حماس وهذا
يشير الى ان حتى الردود الكلاميه اصبحت
اعلى
بالتراش لربما المتحدث باسم حركه حماس عبد
اللطيف القنوع قال بان هذه التصريحات
المتكرره من قبل نتنياهو وجيشه تعكس
الازمه التي تمر بها حكومه اسرائيل وبان
او تخفي تاكل قوه الرضع لدى ولكن مصادر او
تقديرات سياسيه
اسرائيليه تقول بان التهدئه ستدخل حيز
التنفيذ صباح غدا الخميس هذا ما هو مرشح
خاصه ان كافه الاطراف غير معنيه بتوسعه
دائره النار او الذهب
في غزه وفي الداخل
بهذا القدر نعم شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعطيات كنت معنا مباشره من انقطاع غزه
الصحفيه الفلسطينيه روان الصراري
[موسيقى]
حمله شرسه اذا تشنها اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
حسب تصريحات مسؤوليها انفسهم ابرزها تصريح
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمام الذي
قال ان وقت الاغتيالات قد حان والاكيد ان
اسرائيل بدورها تعيش حاله استنفار تحسبا
لاي هجمات مرتقبه بهذا الخصوص قال المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي دانيال هاغاري ان
التهديد يبقى قائما مضيفا انه سيتم النظر
فيما اذا كان سيتم تخفيف التعليمات على
السكان ام لا من جهتها نقلت صحيفه
ستظل ساريه على السكان الاقرب الى قطاع
غزه
اظهرت صور متداوله اثار سقوط صواريخ في
عسقلان حيث اصيبت مباني وسيارات بصوره
مباشره جراءت صواريخ التي لم تتمكن
اسرائيل من اسقاطها
[موسيقى]
واو
نتابع مباشره من القدس مع مدير مكتب
العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلبي من حدود قطاع
غزه زياد اهلا بك معنا بدايه ما الذي
رصدته من صواريخ من القطاع وكذلك من غارات
اسرائيليه على القطع
زياد هل تسمعني زياد حلبي هل تسمعني
طيب بصعوبه الان اسمع الان
اسمعته زياد من صواريخ اطلقت من القطاع
حتى الان على الاقل في الساعه الاخيره
وكذلك الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
قبل نحو 20 دقيقه كانت الرشقه الاخيره من
الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه اتجاه
هذه المنطقه منطقه ما يسمى بغلاف قطاع غزه
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه القريبه من الحدود
نسبيا صواريخ قصيره المدى جرى اعتراض بعض
الصواريخ في المقابل شنت اسرائيل المزيد
من الغارات وخاصه غارات طالت منازل
لقياديين وكوادر في الجهاد الاسلامي في
الساعه الاخيره الجهاد الاسلامي هددت بانه
اذا استمرت اسرائيل في تدمير المنازل
التابعه للعائلات عمليا فان الجهاد
الاسلامي ستكثف القصف لتل ابيب تحديدا هذه
الليله طبعا وفق الجيش الاسرائيلي اطلق
469 صاروخا حتى التاسع ونصف مساء طبعا
بلغت اكثر من 480 عفوا تم اعتراض 153
صاروخ
153 صاروخا وفق الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا نعم
نتنياهو قال ان العمليه الاسرائيليه في
غزه ستستمر السؤال الى متى زياد
هذا يبدو يعني التصريح متوقعا لان عمليا
لا يستطيع عندما تقصف تل ابيب للمره
الثانيه في رشقات
متعاقبه لا يستطيع بعدها بدقائق ان يتحدث
عن وقف لاطلاق النار ولهذا عمليا اختار ان
يتحدث بهذا الشكل لكن ما لفت في مؤتمره
الصحافي اكثر هو حديثه او محاوله تسويق
انجاز هذا يفهم احيانا بانه محاوله لرسم
مشهد ختامي نتنياهو يتحدث عن تغيير معادله
واغتيالات مفاجئه تحددها اسرائيل وتتحكم
بها وان كان عمليا اغفل بانه يكرر ما فعله
لبيت قبل تسعه اشهر فقط ايضا جرى اغتيال
قياديين في الجهاد الاسلامي من قبل
الحكومه السابقه ويتكرر الامر بمعنى هذه
المعادله ليست وليده هذه المره على المقلب
الاخر ايضا الجاد الاسلامي يقصف اكثر من
مره تباعا تل ابيب يمكن له ان يتحدث عن
مشهد ختامي ايضا قوي نسبيا يمكن عندها
للطرفين ان يصل الى وقف متبادل ومتوازن
لاطلاق النار بواساطه مصريه لكن في
الساعات الاخيره نسمع عن نوع من الصعوبه
لدى الوسيط المصري في اقناع الطرفين بسبب
بعض الشروط الجهاد يشترط الان ان يتسلم
جثمان خضر عدنان الشيخ خضر عدنان الذي
عمليا توفي في السجن الاسرائيلي الى اضافه
الى بعض الجثمين لمقاتلي الجهاد ووقف
الاغتيالات هذه امور قد يصعب على نتنياهو
ان يمررها في بيئته اليمنيه المتطرفه نعم
السؤال الاخير زياد كذلك في هذه المواجهه
في جوله تصعيد هذه الحديث عن اسرائيل
والجهاد الاسلامي فقط اين هي حماس
زياد يبدو انك لا تسمعني سمعتني زياد اكرر
السؤال مشكله مشكله في الاتصال الحديث في
هذه المواجهه عن طرفين عن اسرائيل والجهاد
الاسلامي فقط اين هي حركه حماس
عمليا
يعني الحديث الاساسي بان الجهاد الاسلامي
هي من يقوم بجل الاطلاق الصواريخ حاليا
وان كان عمليا الاعلان خرج عن غرفه الغرفه
المشتركه للفصائل بمعنى ان جميع الفصائل
قد تكون شاركت في اطلاق الصواريخ ولكن
اساسا الجهاد الاسلامي تتولى الامر اكثر
قبل بعض الوقت سقط صاروخ في البحر قربه
الابيب بحسب المعلومات الوارده الينا في
هذا الاطار عمليا كما كنا نتحدث عن عمليه
قصف تل ابيب ووسط اسرائيل
الحديث هو اكثر فعليا عن المواجهه مع
الجهاد الاسلامي لانه يتولى اطلاق معظم
الصواريخ عمليا في الساعات الاخيره على
الاقل ربما في الرشقه
ربما في الرشقه الاولى من الصواريخ التي
اطلقت شاركت جميع الفصائل حاليا هناك نع
يد يعني الحديث على قصه الصاروخ الذي سقط
في البحر هذا لم يتاكد بعد هناك بعض
المعلومات المتضاربه حول هذا الامر ايا
كان جرى قصف تل ابيب مرتين هذا اليوم على
الاقل شكرا جزيلا لك زياد حلبي مدير مكتب
العربيه في فلسطين كنت معنا من حدود قطاع
غزه
[موسيقى]
مشهد عوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي يكتمل
شيئا فشيئا في اخر هذه الخطوات توجيه
العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز دعوه رسميه لرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد من اجل المشاركه في القمه العربيه
التي تنعقد في التاسع عشر من شهر مايو
جاري في جده ويتسلم الرئيس السوري الدعوه
من سفير السعوديه في الاردن نايف السديري
في لقاء جمعهما بالعاصمه السوريه دمشق
وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان قرار دعوه
سوريا جاء انطلاقا من روابط الاخوه التي
تجمع الشعبين وحرصا على الاسهام في تطوير
العمل العربي المشترك وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه من جهاته شكر
الرئيس السوري العاهل السعوديه بالقول ان
انعقاد القمه العربيه المقبله في السعوديه
سيعزز العمل العربي المشترك لتحقيق تطلعات
الشعوب العربيه
وتعد هذه اول دعوه تتلقاها دمشق للمشاركه
في اجتماع جامعه الدول العربيه منذ اندلاع
النزاع السوري في 2011 وكانت قمه سرت في
ليبيا عام 2010 اخر قمه حضرها الاسد قبل
تجميد عضويه بلاده في جامعه الدول العربيه
في العاملات
نتابع من دمشق عبر خدمه معنا من هناك عبد
الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحافي استاذ عبد
الحميد اهلا بكم معنا كيف يمكن النظر الى
هذه الدعوه للقمه العربيه من قبل السعوديه
دمشق بعد 12 عاما من الغياب
مساء الخير استاذ صهيب المشاهدين
في الحقيقه ينظر الى هذه الخطوه بانها
تطوي صفحه مرحله وعشريه سوداء في سوريا
وكذلك مرحله وعشريه غير متجانسه بين سوريا
وحاضنتها العربيه والعالم العربي بالتالي
هذه الخطوه السعوديه او هذا التوجه
السعودي لم ياتي من فراغ ولم ياتي قفزا
فوق كثيرا من الوقائع والمعطيات السوريه
المستجده خلال السنوات عشره الماضيه وكذلك
لم تاتي من فراغ في مواجهه اي طرف عربي لم
يكن لديه الرغبه في مثل هذا التوجه
السعوديه عملت
سوريا للحضن العربي وللجامعه العربيه كما
تفضلت يعني خطوه تعيد سوريا الى الى هذه
المجموعه ولكن الازمه
وملفاتها المتشعبه ما تزال موجوده
الازمه السوريه كيف ستسهم عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه في حل قضايا اللاجئين
مثلا المعتقلين المفقودين وتهريب المخدرات
وكذلك الفصائل الاجنبيه المسلحه الموجوده
في الاراضي السوريه كل هذه الملفات امامها
العديد من علامات الاستفهام
صحيح وهذا ما وضعته هذا الذي اريد ان اكمل
به حديثي هذا ما وضعته الرباعيه العربيه
بوجود السعوديه ومصر والاردن والعراق
كخارطه طريق امام سوريا بدات من اجتماع
جده وزياره الوزير الخارجيه السوري الى
جده بعد ذلك لقاء عمان الخماسي ويبدو ان
هذه الخارطه كانت صريحه وواضحه في التعاطي
مع الجانب السوري ووضعتها على طاوله
التفاوض بكل وضوح وشفافيه تشخيصا دقيقا
فيما يتعلق بتهريب المخدرات تصنيع
المخدرات الامن الحدود بين الدول العربيه
وسوريه المساله عوده اللاجئين مساله
الجانب الامني عموما في سوريا وكذلك
المساله السياسيه وتم ترتيب هذه الاولويات
في
باتباعا الجانب الامني فالجانب الانساني
في الجانب السياسي التزامن الذي حدثه هو
ان التفاعل من الجانب السوري مع هذه
القضايا دفع الجانب العربي على او
المبادره الاردنيه خطوه مقابل خطوه دفع
الجانب العربي الرباعيه العربيه الى تطوير
مواقفها وبالتالي الازمه السوريه لا
يستطيع احد حلها لا في الداخل السوري ولا
في المحيط بين وضحاها الجانب السوري اليوم
لا يستطيع كدوله سوريه اليوم لوحدها فقط
وتبعات هذه الازمه يعني ذلك خطوه بخطوه
كما تفضل عبد الحميد طيب قبل ان ينتهي
الوقت نقطه اخرى لافته في هذا التقارب
العربي السوري الان الولايات المتحده
انتقدت يوم الاحد بالتحديد قرار عوده
سوريا لشغل مقعدها في جامعه الدول العربيه
والساده عبد الحميد كيف
وقالت انه واشنطن قالت ان دمشق لا تستحق
هذه الخطوه يعني بهذه العباره كيف تقرا
الموقف العربي هذا تجاه سوريا رغم
الانتقاد الامريكي
حقيقه اقراه في باتجاهين الاول ان اراده
عربيه ذات قرار سيادي استقلالي بدات
تتبلور في المحيط العربي ولدي العواصم
العربيه الوازنه السعوديه والامارات
والقاهره وهذا جانب والجانب الاخر ان
الجانب العربي بعد ان خبر السياسه
الامريكيه وبعد ان وصل الى قناعه بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في سياستها في
الشرق الاوسط وفي المحيط الاقليمي لا
تكترث كثيرا لمصالح شركائها وحلفائها
فانتهجوا نهجا ذا طابع استقلالي وفق اراده
عربيه واضحه بضروره العمل على اعاده سوريا
الى حاضنتها العربيه ضمن التحولات التي
تطرا في العالم سواء على المستويين
الاقليمي والعربي او على المستوى الدولي
والعرب يبدو وكانهم اليوم يستطيعون وضع او
يضعون انفسهم على طاوله اللاعبين الدوليين
بعد ان يتمكنوا من ترتيب بيتهم العربي
لذلك اعتقد بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حين بدات مواربه في مواقفها مره
تقول باننا لا نريد لا نوافق على ولا ندعم
التطبيع العربي وتقول مره اخرى اننا نحن
العرب فرصه لكي يتحدثوا مع الرئيس السوري
ومع الحكومه السوريه هذه حقيقه عمليه
استداره او اداره لم تستعد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قادره على اعطاء
الاوامر وتنفيذها في الجانب التركي بحث
التركيه عن امنها
واستقلاليه قرارها جاءت الى دمشق واليوم
تفاعل الامر ايضا ارى ذلك في الجانب
العربي الذي يصر على ان يكون قراره قراره
استقلاليا بعيدا عن كل الاملاءات الاخرى
شكرا جزيلا لكم الاستاذ عبد الحميد توفيق
الكاتب الصحافي السوري كنت مباشره من دمشق
[موسيقى]
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه لجنه الامن في
الخرطوم تطالب باعلان حاله الطوارئ
والتعبئه العامه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه انها ستحمل قاده السودان
مسؤوليه استمرار العنف مشدده على انه لا
حل عسكريا للازمه في السودان هذا واعربت
الخارجيه الامريكيه عن امتنانها للسعوديه
على استضافه محادثات بين طرفي الصراع
بالسودان
نعمل مع السعوديه للوصول الى وقف اطلاق
نار دائم في السودان واكدنا للشركاء
والحلفاء ان لا حل عسكريا للازمه نحن
ممتنون للسعوديه على استضافه محادثات جده
بين طرفي الصراع ونؤكد اننا سنحمل قاده
السودان مسؤوليه استمرار العنف
اوسط لجنه الامن في الخرطومه الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان باعلان التعبئه العامه
وادخال البلاد في حاله طوارئ وحظر التجوال
وطلبت اللجنه في توصيات رفعتها الى رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان بالعمل
الفوري لمعالجه الكارثه الغذائيه الحاصله
في البلاد مطالبه اياه بالتصدي بحزم لقوات
الدعم السريع واصفه اياها بالميليشيا
المتمرده
اشتدت المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقتي بحري وام درمان في
العاصمه الخرطوم واعلن الجيش السوداني عن
سيطرته على منطقه بحري بعدما شهدت سماء
الخرطوم اعمده دخان وغارات عنيفه بين طرفي
النزاع
[موسيقى]
وازمه السودان تتواصل في ظل عجز الاصوات
الداعيه الى التهدئه عن اقناع الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع بوقف اطلاق النار لكن
السيناريو الحالي للمعارك كان سيبدو
مختلفا لو ان قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان لم ينجو من عمليه اقتحام
مقر اقامته عند بدايه هذه المواجهات وكاله
كشفت النقابه عن تفاصيل لم تعرض من قبل
حول عمليه الاقتحام هذه والتي نفذها
مقاتلو قوات الدعم السريع خلال الساعات
الاولى من اندلاع الصراع رؤيه تقول بان
اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان حدث بالفعل وذلك
نقلا عن عشرات مصادر من طرفي الصراع
والجزئيه الاكثر اثاره في محاوله الاقتحام
هذه هي التصدي البرهان بنفسه للمقاتلين
التابعين للدعم السريع تقول وكاله رويترز
فنقلا عن احد حراس البرهان الشخصيين فان
قائد الجيش حمل بندقيه كلاشنكوف وفتح
النار بنفسه قبل ان ينقله رجال الامن الى
مكان امن وقال الحارس الذي طلب عدم نشر
اسمه ان مقاتلي قوات الدعم السريع قتلوا
اكثر من ثلاثين من حراس البرهان في هذه
المعركه التي تلت الاقتحام قبل ان ينسحبوا
وكانت قوات الدعم السريع قد نشرت مقاطع
فيديو خلال اليوم الثاني للمعارك تقول
انها من داخل مقر اقامه البرهان
[موسيقى]
وفي السودان دائما لم يسلم حتى المرضى من
تداعيات صراع الجنرلين ويتحمل المرضى
فاتوره قد تكلفهم حياتهم بعد 28 هجوما على
مرافق الرعايه الصحيه في السودان العديد
من المرضى في الخرطوم نزحوا الى مناطق
اخرى وهو ما سبب ضغطا وازمه في مراكز
الكلى التي تعاني اصلا من نقص الادويه
مرصد العربيه محمد عثمان زار احد مراكز
غسيل الكلى في مدينه بورسودان في ولايه
البحر الاحمر واعاده تقرير التالي
مشاهدينا انا الان في مركز بورسودان
لامراض وجراح حتى الكلى من المعروف ان
القطاع الصحي من القطاعات التي تاثرت بشكل
كبير جراء الحرب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع سنقف على ما يجري داخل هذا المركز
على اعتبار انه يحتوي على 30 ماكينه غسيل
لمرضى الكلى ان كان هنالك واحد من المرضى
من الخرطوم
يعني الواحد كان بغسل في مركز فضيل
والمركز بقى
ومشينا على مركز في ابو ادم
والمركز برضه وقف قمت اتحركت على اساس من
بنات المنطقه اصلا
الاسبوع انا عندي غسلتين في الاسبوع اربعه
ساعات اربعه ساعات ولان الامر عندي لا
يرتبط بالمهنه فقط بقدر ارتباطه بواقع
انساني قد يتفاقم سريعا في هذا المجال
طلبنا من السلطات القائمه التدخل وكانت
الاستجابه سريعا بعد نصف ساعه ودار هذا
الحوار
تخص الولايه هنا يعني زي مشكله المويه
المركز مع الضغط الكبير بتاع العينين
اضطرينا نفتح ورديات اضافيه بالتالي عندنا
اشكاليه في النوايا فمنحتاج منك انه توفر
لنا عليه الاقل تنكرين في الاسبوع بوادي
20 طن ده يمكن الطلب
بالاضافه لانه بالتعاون مع وزاره الصحه
تساعدونا في غير غير المستهلكات الاساسيه
بتاعت الغسيل الحاجات المعينه للغسله ناس
الشايش والبطن والبلاسر المويه المحتاج لا
نحنا
التزام يعني ابتداء في الكل اسبوع مرتين
ملتزمين بها في كميه من الوافدين
للولايه وبالتالي الضغط على على المركز
كان كبير جدا جدا نحن ان شاء الله هنجيب
معاك في المزرعه دي وكله معيناتها ان شاء
الله مع الجهاز
هذه الولايه تعاني اشكالات كبيره جدا
تتعلق
بالمياه وبالتالي هذا يضع ضغط كبير جدا
على القطاع الصحي وبالتحديد على مراكز
غسيل الكلى هنا في هذه المدينه بورسودان
التي من المتوقع ان تستقبل اعداد كبيره
جدا من المرضى القادمين من الخرطوم محمد
عثمان لقناته العربيه والحدث من مدينه
بورسودان بولايه البحر الاحمر شرقي
السودان
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد على ان بلاده
ستبقى امنه وذلك غداه الهجوم الذي ادى الى
مقتل ثلاثه من رجال الامن وزائرين اثنين
في جزيره جربه خلال موسم الحج اليهودي
وادانا سعيد خلال اجتماع لمجلس الامن
القومي هذه العمليه الاجراميه مطمئنه
للشعب التونسي والعالم ان استقرار بلاده
لن يتزعزع رغم هذه المحاولات الجبانه على
حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يدخل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بتحديات عده وعرقله
صعبه دفعته للبحث عن تحالفات سياسيه تقوي
من حظوظه للفوز بولايه الرئاسيه الجديده
المزيد من التفاصيل مع الزميله روان حمزه
في هذا العرض
[موسيقى]
اختبار صعب يدخله الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لتتويج عقدين من حكمه بولايه
رئاسيه جديده واخيرا كما ينص الدستور يدخل
اردوغان الانتخابات بمواجهه سته احزاب
معارضه متحالفه ضده لكن العلاقه القريبه
التي اسسها اردوغان مع القطاع المحافظ تعد
اهم عنصر سانده في السلطه اضافه الى قاعده
حزبيه قويه حلفاء الرئيس التركي لجانب
حزبه العداله والتنميه هي احزاب صغيره
لكنها قد تحسم السباق الانتخابيه المتقارب
لتضمن له تجاوز عتبه الخمسين بالمئه في
الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات منها احزاب
اسلاميه صغيره تجد نفسها تحظى بتاييد
متصاعد خصوصا حزب الرفاه الجديد ورغم ترشح
زعيمه فاتح اربكان فانه عاد وانسحب واعلن
صراحه دعمه لاردوغان وكذلك يوجد حزب
الحركه القوميه المتحالف مع اردوغان وساهم
في اب السلطه والحفاظ على اغلبيته
بالبرلمان ايضا من ضمن الاحزاب التي تحالف
معها اردوغان حزب الدعوه الحره ينتمي
مؤسسه عرقيا للاكراد ويصنفون ايدولوجيا
اسلاميين محافظين لذا يوصف الحزب عاده
بانه حزب كردي اسلامي
اردوغان رحب بدعم حزب الدعوه الحره حيث
يمنحه هذا الدعم فرصه للحصول على اصوات في
مناطق كرديه كان يخشى ان تكون سببا في
خسارته حزب اليسار الديمقراطي ضمن قائمه
داعمي اردوغان رغم العداء التاريخي فهو
حزب علماني اصيل كان للحزب ثقه له الكبير
منذ عام
1999 عندما حصل على 136 مقعدا في البرلمان
الا انه تدهور بعد وفاه زعيمه بولند
اجاويد ولم يعد له اي مقعد ادراج هذا
الحزب رغم ضاله تاثيره يبرز غرابه
التحالفات التي دفعت تيارات
للاصطفاف اضطراريا رغم اختلاف
الايديولوجيا من اجل تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه
[موسيقى]
رجب طيب اردوغان نهايه السبعينات انضم الى
حزب الخلاص الوطني بقياده نجم الدين
اربكان
عام
1983 عدم الساحه السياسيه كقيادي في حزب
الرفاه
عام
1994 انتخب رئيسا لبلديه اسطنبول
1997 اضطر الى الاستقاله
عام
1998 ودين بتهمه التحريض على الكراهيه
الدينيه اقصي عن الحياه السياسيه
يوليو 2001 اجازت له المحكمه الدستوريه
العوده للسياسه
اغسطس 2001 اسس حزب العداله والتنميه الذي
يتراسها
عام 2002 فاز حزبه بالانتخابات التشريعيه
من 2003 حتى 2014 تسلم منصب رئيس الوزراء
اغسطس 2014 فاز بانتخابات الرئاسه كاول
رئيس منتخب مباشره
وفي مقابله خاصه اجراها الزميل طاهر بركه
اشار الرئيس حزب العداله والتنميه في
ولايه اسطنبول عثمان نوري
بان اولويات حزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات الحاليه هو تذكير المواطنين
بان تركيا باتت تنافس الدول المتقدمه في
مجالات عداد دون اي تطرق الى اعاده هيمنه
التيارات الاسلاميه او المحافظين على
الحكم او الاقتصاد
كل انتخابات نخوضها تتطلب تجديدا وما
نقصده هو نقل تركيا الى مراحل متقدمه من
التطور فقد غدت تركيا اليوم دوله تصنع
طائراتها الحربيه بنفسها بعد ان كانت
تستورد حتى عجلاتها من الخارج ورفعت عدد
مطاراتها من 20 مطارا الى 60 وصارت تصنع
سياراتها بعد ان كانت تستورد اصغر
المنتجات الصناعيه وستغدو من الدول
المعتبره والمعدوده في التكنولوجيا الفضاء
والصحه وما وصلت اليه في التعليم نحن
واثقون من دعم المواطنين لنا في انتخابات
القرن التركي
وطاهر معنا الان مباشره من اسطنبول طاهر
اهلا بك معنا
باقي اربعه ايام على موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ما الذي لمسته من على ما يركز
المرشحون في هذه المرحله في هذا الشوط
الاخير من هذا السباق الرئاسي في تركيا
في الشوط الاخير صهيب من هذه الانتخابات
حاميه الوطيس في ايامها الاخيره في
حملاتها الانتخابيه التركيز يبدو انه اخذ
مسارا اخر غير كل ما كنا نسمع عنه في
الفتره الماضيه وسنعدده لاحقا اليوم وصل
الامر الى تسريب صور تعتبر بمثابه فضيحه
جنسيه لمحرم انجي احد المرشحين لسباق
الرئاسه وهو مرشح حزب البلد وقد غرد قبل
قليل قائلا انها هذه صور مفبركه وما هي
الا محاوله يائسه من جماعه فتح الله جولين
لمحاوله احباطه وثنيه عن الترشح للرئاسه
لماذا لانه هو متهم بانه سيشتت اصوات
المعارضه هو منشق عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري
هو وايضا ينطبق الامر على تشتيت الاصوات
على المرشح الرابع سنان اوغان مرشح تحالف
الاجداد او تحالف الذي يعني من اهم احزاب
وحزب الظفر فبالتالي هناك فرقاء تشتغل
فعلا من اجل ثاني هؤلاء عن الترشح لانه
سيشتت الاصوات اذا هذا بالنسبه الى تسريب
هذا الموضوع اما في الشق الاخر فهناك من
لم يسرب حتى الان ولكن تحدث عنه اردوغان
شخصيا عندما تهدد
بتسجيل او بتسريب بعض التسجيلات للقاءات
كمالك مرشح تحالف المعارضه تحالف الامه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قال له بمن
التقيت اين اختفيت لمده ساعات في محطات
الوقود وفي بعض المطاعم في الولايات
المتحده في اشاره الى انه التقى بجماعه
فتح الله غولين
وزرعته وحليفه
السيدات اذا طاهر طيب اجريت اليوم هذه
المقابله مع رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه
الحزب الحاكم في اسطنبول طاهر ما الذي
لمسته من حديثك الى هذا المسؤول هل حزب
اردوغان لديه ثقه كبيره دعنا نقول بان
اردوغان سيربح ولايه رئاسيه جديده في هذه
الانتخابات
واثقون جدا يعني استطيع ان اقول ذلك
بصراحه ويبدو ان الامر يتعدى الدعايه
الانتخابيه التي يروجون لها ودعني اقول
لانه يعني وعدنا المشاهدين بانه نعود الى
البرامج الانتخابيه التي كان يتم التركيز
عليها عندما سالتني في السؤال الاول بانه
هم فعلا كانوا يركزون على الحفاظ على
القيم المجتمعيه المحافظه وهذا هو صلب
حمله اردوغان الانتخابيه اضافه الى
الابقاء على اللاجئين اضافه الى الاستمرار
بموضوع سياسه الفائده اضافه الى الاستثمار
بالجنسيه وعدد من القضايا التي ذهب تحالف
الامه الى النقيض تماما فيها وفي حملاته
الانتخابيه ويدعو الى النشر الافكار
المتحرره الى موضوع الى تغيير موضوع
الفائده وبالتالي الاستقلاليه القرار قرار
البنك المركزي الى اعاده اللاجئين الى
ديارهم والى اعاده العلاقه مع الغرب كما
كانت ليس كما فعل اردوغان بالاتجاه الى رو
اكثر على حساب الغرب بالعوده الى موضوع
المقابله اجرينا اللقاء معه واثقون جدا
بالفوز لدرجه انه قال لنا حتى عمات وخالات
داود اوغلو وعلي بابا جان لن يصوتنا لهما
واتضح انه بالفعل
لا استطيع ان اقنع عمتي المحافظه بان تصوت
لي لماذا لانهم انضم الى تحالف الامه
التحالف المعارض الذي يضمن حزب الشعب
الجمهوري العلماني العلماني وهو يعني طبعا
التقليديون والمحافظون يعارضونه بالتالي
يبدو انه عمه داود اوغلو عادت وقالت انا
معه في اي مكان يكون الى هنا سنرى هذا
الشد والجذب بين الاطراف المتنازعه صهيب
صحيح شكرا جزيلا لك وبانتظار المزيد من
المقابلات ان اعلم انك اجريت المزيد من
المقابلات مع المسؤولين في هذه الانتخابات
وطبعا التغطيه الواسعه يوم الانتخابات معك
طاهر طبعا وبقيه الزملاء كذلك على الارض
في تركيا طاهر بركه شكرا جزيلا لك حتى
الان من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا لا يزال التصعيد سيد الموقف
في العديد من الجبهات هي ما في معركه
باخمت المستمره منذ اشهر في اخر التطورات
الميدانيه اكد مسؤولا عسكري اوكراني كبير
ان قوات الكلاب شنت هجمات مضاده في اجبر
القوات الروسيه على التراجع في بعض
الاماكن هذا وقال قائد القوات البريه في
الجيش الاوكراني او الكسندر ان جنوده شنوا
هجمات مضاده فعاله دفعت القوات الروسيه
الى الانسحاب بمسافه تصل الى كيلو مترين
على الطرف الاخر اكدت قوته باجنر على لسان
قائدها
تواصل التقدم في العمق الغربي للمدينه
ويبقى الوضع ضبابيا الى حد ما في حيث كان
الجيش الاوكراني قد قال ايضا ان قوته
الحقت اضرارا جسيمه بوحده روسيه قرب ضخمه
كما اضاف الجيش الاوكراني دائما ان موسكو
اضطرت الى استخدام القوات الجيش النظامي
بسبب الخسائر الفادحه في صفوف مجموعه
باكنر التي لم تنجح لحد الان في السيطره
على المدينه بشكل كلي
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الحكومه
الباكستانيه تطلب من الجيش التدخل لحفظ
الامن في اسلام اباد
اهلا بكم من جديد طلبه الحكومه
الباكستانيه الجيش بالتدخل الفوري لحفظ
الامن في العاصمه حيث تشهد الشوارع اعمال
شغب واعتداءات على الاماكن العامه من قبل
مؤيدي رئيس الحكومه السابق عمران خان من
جهه اخرى قرر قاضي التحقيق تمديد احتجاز
عمران خان لمده ثمانيه ايام ورفض القاضي
طلب محاميه بالافراج عنه
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين في ختام اخبار الساعه لهذه
الليله نذكر بالاخبار العاجله التي وردت
قبل قليل على شاشه العربيه نقلا عن رئيس
مجلس القياده اليمني في تصريحات خاصه
لقناتنا لقناه العربيه اكد ان مشاريع
استراتيجيه للبرنامج السعودي في عدن وعده
محافظات
واكد العليمي كذلك ان الحرب التي شنتها
الميليشيات على البلاد دمرت كل القطاعات
في اليمن العليمي اضافها للعربيه بان دعم
السعوديه لليمن في مجال الطاقه الكهربائيه
خفف من معاناه اليمنيين كذلك شكر العليمي
جهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه في احلال
السلام في اليمن كذلك العليمي قضى للعربيه
بانه على الميليشيات الاستجابه لمشروع
خارطه الطريق التي تبنتها السعوديه وقال
ان الميليشيات تستخدم الهدن استراحه محارب
ونحن جربناها كما قال عليمي وقال باننا
نريد وقف اطلاق النار بشكل شامل ونهائي في
اليمن بهذه التصريحات ناتي نختار مقبره
ساعه شكرا على المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات